there's a lot of people that I look at
whose names you don't know some of them
I've written about I wrote about them
because they inspire me if you read
leaders eat last I wrote about Bob
Chapman who was somebody I met and
decided to write about because I thought
he was so amazing and I've been so lucky
that he's become a friend I wrote about
Johnny Bravo a remarkable remarkable
leader that every time I'm with either
of these people I learned something new
I've written about most the people I
look up to but there's some other people
that I look up to that I that I think
are remarkable I'll tell you to Lady
Gaga and the Pope there's a combination
so and I'll tell you why because both of
them seem to stand for something bigger
than their job like Lady Gaga offers
people a sense of belonging a sense of
cause she refers them as my little
monsters and she's the patron saint of
misfits you know that if you felt
uncomfortable and you you felt like you
were the weird one at school for the
first time in your life you actually
feel like a valued member of a community
of people just like you that's really
important that's what leaders do right
leaders create community and tribes and
make us feel like we belong and make us
feel like we matter and I think Lady
Lady Gaga has done that in spades
she's also remarkably consistent in her
cause she has a contract
she's a spokesperson for Mac makeup and
they were releasing a new lipstick color
and I happened to watch the press
conference and I thought how is she
gonna bring her cause of inclusion
inclusion for a lipstick and I watched
the press conference and she talked
about how she specifically chose a color
that no matter the color of your skin or
what ethnicity you were this color would
go with you I thought my god she even
does it for the lipstick it was amazing
the Pope also stands on the lever level
higher than his job you know he's the
CEO of Catholicism but you know that's
his job you know that that that that's
his that's his product right but he
enjoys love from people who aren't
Catholics
I know atheists who love the Pope right
that's incredible that means he stands
for something bigger than religion and
bigger than faith though he uses
religion and faith to advance his cause
as just cause at the end of the day his
causes more human than
is religious right it's about serving
those who cannot serve themselves it's
about remembering that there are other
people besides us who need help and like
I said he enjoys love and devotion and
respect unlike the previous Pope from
Protestants and Jews and Muslims and
atheists and I find that quite
remarkable quite remarkable
[Music]
[Music]